I'm Callie reading four reviewer Kevin
Kiner Xebec Luigi's Mansion may directly
trace its lineage to the Super Mario
franchise but the series is in many ways
its complete antithesis
whereas Mario's adventures are filled
with platforming challenges to overcome
Luigi's have been decidedly more
methodical emphasizing careful
observation over quick reflex Luigi's
Mansion three very much continues this
tradition but the tightly crafted set
pieces assembled here illustrate just
how compelling the style of gameplay
remains and the new mechanics in freer
structure make it perhaps the best
installment in the series yet once again
Mario's cowardly brother finds himself
unwittingly thrust into the role of hero
when Mario Princess Peach and her
entourage of toads are kidnapped shortly
after the group checks into the last
resort hotel Luigi narrowly avoids this
same fate by escaping down a laundry
chute and landing in the hotel's
basement where he soon reunites with
professor egad and his trusty
poltergeist a modified vacuum cleaner
that can suck up ghosts the poltergeist
serves as the basis of Luigi's entire
range of actions in Luigi's Mansion 3
despite being a more add up jumper than
his brother Luigi's feet are planted
firmly to the floor throughout nearly
the entire adventure his primary means
of interacting with the environment
instead comes through the poltergeists
numerous abilities on top of being able
to suck up debris and blow out air the
vacuum comes equipped with both the
strobe and the dark light from Luigi's
Mansion dark moon complimenting these is
a handful of satisfying new abilities
the suction shot fires a plunger that
can touch to certain objects allowing
Luigi to swing or pull them while the
bursts release a gust of air that knocks
crowds of enemies back and lifts the
plumber momentarily off the ground the
most vital addition to Luigi's ghost
hunting repertoire however is the slam
latch onto a ghost and you'll charge up
a meter that lets you bash them
repeatedly on the floor inflicting extra
damage not only do these new abilities
feel like natural extensions of Luigi's
skill set they inject a welcomed bit of
action to the gameplay and open up new
approaches for taking on enemies you can
slam one ghost into any others that are
nearby damaging multiple foes at once
and later encounters will force you to
use the other skill
at your disposal as well making battles
consistently enjoyable outside of combat
the Poltergust most significant new
feature is the ability to summon a GUI
doppelganger of Luigi called GUI gee
this goopy clone retains the same
abilities as Luigi but his gelatinous
body can slip through fences grates and
even spike traps letting him bypass
seemingly insurmountable obstacles and
discover hidden corners of the hotel
certain enemies and objects will also be
much too large for Luigi to swing on his
own requiring GUI jeez extra set of
hands and a number of rooms feature
pressure-sensitive tiles that one
character will need to stand on while
the other acts independently once you
unlock GUI Guk through almost the entire
adventure cooperatively with another
nearby player and the game lends itself
well to either co-op or solo play many
of the puzzles you'll encounter require
Luigi and GUI G to work in tandem which
makes exploring the hotel with a friend
enjoyable solo players meanwhile can
swap between Luigi and Luigi to quickly
take control of either character as the
situation demands
you'll never encounter a scenario that
can't be overcome solo although a
handful of bosses and puzzles are
clearly designed with a second player in
mind and are a bit more cumbersome when
you're juggling both characters much
like dark moon Luigi's Mansion 3 makes
clever use of your small clash of
abilities every puzzle you encounter
while exploring the last resort can be
surmounted by observing your
surroundings and employing some
combination of these skills although it
certainly won't seem that way for many
you'll frequently come across puzzles
that offer no obvious solution which
makes finally figuring out the answer
all the more satisfying on top of that
the hotel houses a wealth of
collectibles to find coins pearls bars
of gold and other valuables are tucked
away in treasure chests toilets in any
other compartment you can imagine
encouraging you to poke around there are
also six unique gems to find on each
floor many of these are deviously hidden
and you'll need to study your
surroundings carefully to figure out how
to uncover them which makes taking the
time to explore every nook and cranny of
the building constantly rewarding each
floor of the last resort is its own
self-contained level and adheres to a
different theme running the gamut from
restaurants and gift shops to medieval
castles and ancient Egyptian pyramids
this variety keeps the adventure
pleasantly surprising throughout gaining
access to a new floor is always a
delight because you never quite know
what to expect
the elevator door opens in order to
reach these floors you'll first need to
take on a boss ghost and retrieve the
elevator button in their possession
these boss encounters are another
highlight each one has a distinct
personality that's charmingly conveyed
through their animations these
personalities help elevate the boss's
above the rather forgettable ones from
dark moon and each battle makes that of
Luigi's skill set in clever ways the
controls however will occasionally get
in your way to shine the dark light you
need to hold the X button which means
you can't move the right analog stick to
adjust your aim while using that ability
the game compensates for this by letting
you aim using motion controls but you're
limited to aiming up and down making an
inelegant solution the suction shot
suffers from a similar issue rounding
out the package are two dedicated
multiplayer modes scare scraper and
scream park the former challenge is up
to eight players either locally or
online to complete successive floors of
a tower within a strict time limit
scream park meanwhile is a local only
party mode in which two teams compete
against one another in one of three
different mini-games both modes can be
fun diversions particularly scare
scraper which straddles the line between
competitive and cooperative however
they're comparatively shallow and lack
the same appeal as the main game while
the multiplayer modes might not hold
your attention for long the strength of
the Luigi's Mansion series has always
stem from the satisfaction of exploring
its carefully constructed settings and
in that regard Luigi's Mansion 3
certainly succeeds this game may not
radically diverge from the series
formula but it offers up another
meticulously crafted set of challenges
to overcome while smoothing out some of
the issues that held dark moon back and
the sense of accomplishment you feel
when you clear a particularly
head-scratching obstacle is just as
potent now as the first time Luigi
unwillingly stepped into a Haunted
Mansion
[Music]